hello i'm johnny knoxville and this is
the wired auto complete interview
can johnny knoxville probably not i used
to could but not anymore
first up
did johnny knoxville probably did johnny
knoxville create jackass i along with
jeff germain and spike jones created
jackass did johnny knoxville pay for the
rental car yes we pay for everything we
break we're not [ __ ] that was the
rental car smash up derby from jackass
number one where i rented a car
had it modified for a crash-up derby and
then i think we had to return it on a
flatbed because it was not drivable
anymore they weren't happy did johnny
knoxville go to jail we got arrested for
trespassing in the tv series
and i was happy because
there was a writer from rolling stone
there and we got him arrested too does
johnny knoxville still skate i never
skated actually i skated when i was 12
or 13 for a while and i skated down my
hill and broke my ankle and my father
was so mad
because i was going to miss baseball
they threw my skateboard into the woods
so that was the end of my skating days
what johnny knoxville what was johnny
knoxville's
best stunt
hmm
i don't know maybe i love bulls so and i
took the gnarliest bull hit of my career
in this new movie jackass forever
so
i'm gonna say the magic trick
from jackass forever okay what does
johnny knoxville
look like now ta-da
gray hair and all i've been coloring my
hair since my late 20s
and i liberated myself during the
pandemic and i don't have to do that
anymore
what was johnny knoxville's
most embarrassing
moment i don't know what my most
embarrassing moment was i don't usually
get that embarrassed i remember when i
was a teenager
and i was playing the game a clue with
this girl that i really liked and i had
gas but i was holding it in
and so i remember rolling the dice and i
moved my guy over into the study or
something and when i reach forward you
know a little gas came out and i was so
embarrassed because i thought oh i've
just blown it so that was pretty
embarrassing what was johnny knoxville's
bull injury oh from well there's been
many bull injuries but this one from
jackass forever i broke my wrist broke
my rib got a concussion had a brain
hemorrhage in the hospital for the
weekend and it took me a few months to
recover from fully i knew i was in
trouble though because when i was in the
back of the ambulance they're asking me
basic questions like who's the president
now and i said ah
obama but i had no clue that i'd broke
my rib i've pulled a rib before like
moving the weird way and you can't even
cough or laugh you know it's very
painful but the broken rib was you
couldn't even barely feel it what is
johnny knoxville
doing next
well from here i go to the daily show
but in my career i'm working on a few
documentaries and i start a hulu series
that steve levitan wrote called
reboot
why johnny knoxville oh these should be
good why does johnny knoxville
always wear converse i'm a creature of
habit it's just one less decision i have
to make and i love converse but i did
recently buy a pair of nike old school
air jordans so now i have two different
styles of shoe why does johnny knoxville
always wear sunglasses i'm wearing my
glasses today
but i think i often wear my sunglasses
out of vanity and their their
prescription though so i can see out of
them why is johnny knoxville
so sexy let's see
no
famous look that's a good question i
have no idea why i'm famous
apparently there's a lot of perverts out
there who like what i do i feel more
approachable than other people just
because i do what i do
and i probably am more approachable than
other people because some actors get
hassled
by people coming up but i'm like if
that's the case you should really go
into another business we're very lucky
to be doing what we're doing and if a
fan must come up and say hello that's
fine you should be able to manage that
pal
why did johnny knoxville retire
retire from what i don't know what
they're talking about
maybe i should
how johnny knoxville how did johnny
knoxville
get his name i was writing for magazines
and i wanted a
snappier name than pj clapp which is my
real name so i took my middle name and
the city i grew up in knoxville and
voila how does johnny knoxville
stay in shape um i like taking hikes and
i'll do 150 push-ups a day but i gotta
say i'm not in the greatest shape
right now christmas got me
how did johnny knoxville become famous
for self-defense equipment article i
wrote it for big brother magazine which
jeff tremaine was the editor and he
convinced me to film it
right we put in one of their skate
videos
uh pepper spray stun gun taser gun and i
shot myself in the chest while wearing a
bulletproof vest i shot myself with the
38. the vest actually dispersed it
pretty well it felt like someone hit you
in the chest with a shovel as hard as
they could and that kind of started us
thinking about jackass
how many
broken bones has johnny knoxville had i
don't know i've never counted but quite
a lot people i've had 16 concussions i
know that but broken bones i don't know
but there's been a lot
can johnny knoxville probably not i used
to could but not anymore can johnny
knoxville roller skating a buffalo herd
wow i tried to roll a skate in a buffalo
herd but turns out roger miller is right
you can can johnny knoxville feel pain
yes i feel pain but luckily i'm not very
in touch with my body my pain tolerance
is probably just about the same as
anyone else's it's my give and [ __ ]
tolerance is real low can johnny
knoxville run for president well i was
thinking i'm glad you asked i was
thinking about announcing my
presidential run
for 2024
so i'm just looking for a running mate
uh if there's anyone out there we man
would be a great running mate right
yes we can
can johnny knoxville sing not a lick
some people's voice would break a glass
mine would split a stump
is johnny knoxville
is johnny knoxville related to jack
nicholson
[Laughter]
no but i love jack nicholson i'm a huge
fan of his we have the same hairline
is johnny knoxville smart
well i wouldn't say smart
[Laughter]
but i'm learning is johnny knoxville a
nice guy no i'm awful terrible what a
[ __ ] bag
is johnny knoxville really
uh xenomorph i'm just old johnny
all right everybody that's it
what'd you think of the questions hope
you liked them until next time
[Music]